bonjour et bienvenue pour ce nouveau 7,8
week-end l'émission dédiée à vos sorties
et vos loisirs aujourd'hui nous
parlerons de la palme du lac à voisins
le bretonneux un concours de jeunes
talents plus de 35 jeunes seront sur
scène samedi soir julie bio la
coordinatrice au centre d'alfred de
vigny nous présentera le concours
l'église évangélique de
voisins-le-bretonneux vous invite à
partir de dimanche à une fête de
l'amitié pour en parler stéphane hlaing
responsable du groupe jeunesse de
l'église évangélique et yanis gauthier
pasteur et coordinateur de l'événement
et dimanche la fronde la france affronte
l'islande en quarts de finale de l'euro
de football
un match à suivre sur écran géant michel
creton adjoint à montigny le bretonneux
est avec nous en plateau
mais tout d'abord à la maison félix de
montigny le bretonneux vous pourrez
découvrir une exposition d'art proposées
par claudia quand pose ce plasticien les
professeurs d'un franco brésilienne
cette exposition rassemble 18 artistes
élèves de claudia campos débutants ou
confirmés les artistes vous propose de
découvrir des oeuvres personnelles et
collectives autour de différentes
matières et supports peinture gravure ou
encore photographies l'exposition vous
accueille jusqu'à ce dimanche
les techniques sont plutôt pour apporter
un plus pour qui chaque personne puisse
s'exprimer
donc à la base de mon enseignement c'est
vraiment la créativité développer dans
une voie plus artistique après la
technique ses dessins peintures des
gravures vidéos photos postées sienne
toujours dans ce but de développer les
maximum leur univers dans
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines se cachent deux jeunes talents
pour les mettre en avant le service
jeunesse de la commune de
voisins-le-bretonneux et le centre
alfred de vigny 1,5 que de nombreux
autres partenaires ont décidé de lancer
un concours j'ai dit bio bonjour bonjour
pourquoi avoir lancé alors un concours
les gens alors à la base c'était on
voulait monter un événement un projet
commun entre le service jeunesse et
prévention de la ville de voisins et le
centre alfred de vigny qui a aussi un
grand public jeune et j'ai eu l'idée du
coup de de mettre en valeur ces jeunes
qui vivent dans la communauté
d'agglomération je sais qu'il ya des
talents cachés et j'avais envie de les
mettre en avant de les mettre sur scène
autour d'un événement commun voilà on
parle de jeunes il y à une tranche d'âge
quand même à respecter oui alors c'est
11 25 ans donc il ya des grands jeunes
aussi quand même des et des plus petits
voilà il est sur scène y aura de 11 à 25
ans parmi les partenaires ce sont des
acteurs vis chinois les jeunes sur scène
seront cédés décinois non pas que en
fait on a voulu agrandir un peu le panel
et du coup on a voilà avec la nouvelle
communauté d'agglomération la sky on
voulait du coup élargir un peu le public
et donc il ya les douze communes qu'ils
pouvaient être des jeunes des douze
communes qui pouvaient sélectionner des
jeunes sur 12 communes ça représente
combien de candidature au moment où vous
avez lancé le concours
alors on a eu on en a eu beaucoup on a
dû faire des sélections puisqu'on
pouvait pas prendre tout le monde sinon
ça aurait fait un show beaucoup trop
long voilà on en attendait encore plus
ont du coup on voudra leur faire dans
deux ans parce que là on va donner la
chance à tout le monde
et on a fait un choix quand même dans
les dents les candidatures qu'on a reçu
puisque on voulait quand même
sélectionné la crème de la crème pour
que le show soit de qualité des choix un
peu douloureux aussi peut-être faune
sauvage loi pour les jeunes oui mais en
même temps on voulait pas les mettre en
difficulté du coup ils ont compris que
voilà il est quand même avoir un public
conséquent et que c'était pas les aider
finalement que de présenter un show qui
serait pas si bien
on a parlé des jeunes il ya la notion de
talent quand on peint de talent qu'on
voit toutes les émissions qu'il peut y
avoir à la télé il pense tout de suite
aux chants ou à la danse est-ce qu'il va
y avoir des talents un peu plus
insolites sur la scène voisins le
bretonneux fugue un peu plus oui alors
évidemment bas comme un incroyable
talent ou d'un ses émissions là il y a
beaucoup de chants et de danses puisque
finalement céder des activités qui sont
facilement accessibles
mais on a quand même réussi à avoir un
magicien est aussi un imitateur de
michael jackson donc voilà c'est un tout
petit en plus il a 11 ans et demi 12 ans
et du coup vraiment il fait quelque
chose de qualité c'est une vraie passion
pour lui et ça me fait plaisir qui monte
sur scène pour nous montrer ça on est à
la veille de l'événement est ce que ils
sont prêts à être qui se sont pressés
comment ils sont sensés et là on était
en montage et justement il y en avait
qui commençait déjà à venir regardez un
peu comment serait la scène et en santé
le stresse un peu monter quand même ils
ont travaillé longtemps parce que en
talent ça se cultive quand même oui ben
non ils ont en plus été accompagnés pour
certains puisque en fait on a lancé donc
les sélections mais à peu près en
février et du coup ils ont de février à
juillet donc ça fait presque six mois
quand même de deux répétitions et ils
ont été accompagnés par les structures
et notamment des des services jeunesse
comme celui de maurepas il ya le studio
de répétition d'elancourt aussi voilà il
ya eu il ya le service jeunesse de
voisins aussi qui a accompagné un groupe
de danse donc c'est un projet qui a
finalement eu beaucoup de partenaires et
on a un gros partenaire aussi on n'en a
pas parlé
c'est illicite dans ce qui nous aide
beaucoup sur sur le sur le spectacle est
aussi radio sensations qui a beaucoup
diffusé l'information et on les remercie
c'était une manière de les accompagner
c'était aussi un moyen pour eux de
contrôler un peu ce qu'ils font dans le
sens où ils sont jeunes
ne se rendent peut-être pas compte de ce
qu'est la scène et de ce qu'ils peuvent
de l'image qui peuvent représenter
c'était aussi ça c'était ça et c'était
aussi parfois les jeunes on a du mal à
les mobiliser et c'est facile c'est plus
facile quand y'a un accompagnateur avec
eux mêmes remplir le dossier
d'inscription parfois pour eux c'est
compliqué donc finalement un adulte ils
ont beau vouloir refuser les adultes cet
âge la mine de rien ils ont quand même
besoin d'avoir un accompagnateur en fait
c'est un concours way qui va voter
comment ça va se passer
alors on a on a réussi à avoir un très
beau jury puisque ses cinq
professionnels 1dans sein une danseuse
laëtitia près on a aussi une chanteuse
née ridge et qui est une chanteuse de
soul gospel un animateur radio de radio
sensations notre partenaire donc julien
et qu'on appelle jules sur la radio est
également également un jeune du conseil
municipal jeunes de voisins puisque
comme c'était un événement jeanne vous
voulez quand même voilà et andy pis mort
qui a fait aussi de la télé un de vos
collègues
voilà qui va venir un comédien donc donc
c'est assez sérieux vous les mettez
vraiment dans le bain a fait pas c'est
pas le petit spectacle de fin d'année on
va dire il aurait grillé way de
dévaluation voilà ils vont noter chaque
prestation donner leur avis et donc six
mois de préparation pour quels enjeux ça
va donner quoi pour eux la fin alors il
ya plusieurs il n'y a qu'un seul
vainqueur
ça peut être un groupe mais il ya qu'un
seul vainqueur il n'y a qu'un lot c'est
la possibilité de faire des premières
parties lors d'événements municipaux de
l'année prochaine mais aussi une scène
complète en fait sûr il ya une salle qui
a été réservé en une date en février où
ils pourront faire un show complet les
gagnants et aussi des chats culturel
d'une grande marque de culturel un
magasin auquel on a parlé du concours
c'est pas que ça il y aura un village
associatif il aura un concert il y aura
un spectacle en quelques mots si vous
deviez me résumer cette soirée alors
dans le village associatif c'est des
stands à destination des jeunes
ils sont presque tous gratuits voilà on
voulait vraiment que
du coup ils puissent ils puissent avoir
des choses rien que pour eux un
événement qui leur ressemblent fait pour
eux par eux parce qu'on a beaucoup de
bénévoles jeunes qui viennent nous aider
et il ya un dj qui va venir faire un set
d'une heure pour commencer dj wax mines
qui vient pendant une heure qui est
assez connu voilà dans le dans le
quartier merci julie billes aux talents
des jeunes saint quentinois et donc à
découvrir samedi 2 juillet au lac de la
sourderie derrière le collège
champollion
les festivités commencent à 18 heures on
continue le foetus week-end le magazine
dédié aux sorties et aux loisirs avec
notre page cinéma pour ce week-end c'est
bertrand pin et des yeux déjà à saint
cyr l'école qui vous donne son coup de
coeur au likoud le couture des usa cette
semaine c'est un film qui est sorti il
ya un petit peu plus d'un mois
qu'ils s'appellent the nice guys un film
de shane black avec rainbow sli et
russell crowe
c'est une comédie qui une comédie
policière qui se déroule dans les années
soixante dix à los angeles
c'est dans la veine les ce qu'on a
appelé les buddy movies à leur chaîne
black c'est celui qui a écrit le
scénario de l'armé fatale donc il
connaît il sait ce que c'est que les
bloody movies les films de copains comme
ça dans une ambiance de ce thriller ou
de communes de oud enquête policière
et là en l'occurrence c'est vraiment
traité comme une très grosse enquête
très drôle c'est l'histoire d'une
sardine starlette qui a disparu on la
soupçonne de s'être suicidé on met un
enquêteur sur le coup cet enquêteur va
devoir s'associer à un autre pseudo
enquêteurs une petite frappe joué par
ryan gosling
évidemment ces deux là sont en rien pour
s'entendre au début et vont tout avoir
pour s'entendre à la fin le scénario est
un peu cousu de fil blanc mais par
contre c'est un vrai bonheur de
deux comédies les deux acteurs sont au
top ils sont à fond complètement dans
leur personnage très très flou très
moque je vous invite à venir le voir ce
week end au cinéma les yeux d'elsa en
version française et en version
originale
toujours du côté des sorties de la
semaine mais cette fois c'est les avis
du 7 des amateurs de septième art manon
labat a été recueillir leurs impressions
regardez c'était sympa c'était assez
originale les acteurs étaient très très
sympa aussi et puis surtout ça m'a
replongé en islande mais ça je ne savais
pas c'était la bonne surprise du film
bons effets aquatiques je pensais que ça
se passait dans une piscine à montreuil
ce qui m'avait plus de la bande-annonce
j'avais vu basse et l'esthétique en fait
quoi là les images la beauté du dessin
et après c'est un peu décevant en terme
d' intrigues de l'histoire cette boule
et qui reflète un peu le
l'esprit camping mais moi
personnellement j'ai trouvé qu'il y
avait des longueurs dans le cadre du 2
ans qui se retrouve dans la maison avec
bernard junod je trouve que c'était pas
approprié à vos films camping souvent
d'il ya 2 3 4 les séries de chine comme
ça mais non elle est bien est réussi et
réussie du 3 au 10 juillet l'église
évangélique de voisins-le-bretonneux
vous invite à une fête de l'amitié
cette semaine commence dès le moi le
jour de dimanche par nombre au parc de
la croix du bois pour un moment
d'échangé stéphane h lun et alice
gauthier sont avec nous en plateau pour
en parler bonjour messieurs
alors je me tourne à vancouver vous
stéphane pourquoi l'église a souhaité
organiser un tel événement c'est un
événement qui va être dédié à simplement
amener de la joie et de la bonne humeur
et puis ça se fait dans des dans un
cadre convivial voilà c'est didier c'est
pour avoir des échanges avec les
personnes surtout voilà partage et
surtout la joie des bon moment juste
avant l'été ça dépasse aussi le cadre de
la simple églises évangéliques alors oui
parce que c'est une association qui a
été mis en place
la fête de l'amitié par chrétiens
d'aujourd'hui et l'objectif c'est de
favoriser les échanges
intergénérationnels et interculturels
ça va bien au delà de l'aspect de
l'église évangélique yann est justement
les changes la rencontre la discussion
c'est nécessaire encore aujourd'hui
c'est très important la communication et
on le voit beaucoup d'incompréhension
parfois on fait
5 km on passe d'un quartier à un autre
et puis c'est des décors différents
et puis beaucoup de des fausses
croyances parfois qui sont dans les
pensées des jeunes des moins jeunes et
l'idée c'est bah justement de fédérer au
travers de deux jeux de kermesse de
barbecue d'essayer de fédérer les
générations et puis les voilà
différentes cultures
l'actualité récente a peut-être
renforcer la volonté de faire ce genre
de rassemblement de rencontre pour
pouvoir peut-être discuter aussi de deux
questions de comme ça si je dirais que
l'actualité c'est une actualité qui est
plutôt chaotique pas plutôt carrément
chaotique et et c'est vrai que bon on
est conscient qu'on va pas changer
l'atmosphère du jour au lendemain mais
mais je dis que si on peut apporter une
petite pierre une petite contribution au
bonheur de des habitants du secteur
c'est c'est déjà pas mal c'est déjà une
réussite pour nous et aussi il ya il ya
quand même un message d'unité d'amour de
paix qu'on essaye de véhicules et pour
justement ne pas encore une fois seul
effet enfermés par par les images qu'on
peut voir à la télé qui sont souvent par
révélatrice de la réalité de la nôtre
vous parlez de kermesse quel sera le
programme qu'est ce qu'il y aura
d'autres ce jour là donc ça va démarrer
à 13 heures avec un barbecue géant
voilà une kermesse qui va se dérouler
tout l'après midi justement et sur les
différents stands d'animations donc des
stands comme l'histoire de tirs au but
ils sont des pistes la peinture les
structures gonflables pour les enfants
mais les espaces d'échangés de
convivialité ça fait partie aussi de de
cet événement voilà pouvoir discuter
avec des personnes aient changé il y
aura aussi du théâtre et des concerts je
crois savoir que vous êtes vous saurez
partie prenante de ces concerts oui la
kermesse elle est suivie à 17 heures
d'un concert avec en première partie un
artiste qui s'appelle junior et puis
j'ai intervient juste après et dans la
suite à 20 heures il y aura une pièce de
théâtre jouée par la compagnie des actes
intitulée lettre aux lettres de paul ou
au parisien
vialis vous parliez tout à l'heure des
habitants du quartier ça s'adresse qu'à
eux où ça peut s'ouvrir à tous ceux qui
oseraient se déplacer quand je dis
quartier c'est parce qu'on a on va on a
on a aussi l'idée de voilà d'inviter
tout le monde et de pas simplement dire
que c'est pour une population type est
pas pour l'autre
donc c'est pour tout le monde la fête de
l'amitié c'est la première à voisins le
bretonneux mais c'est quand même un
rendez vous qui a maintenant six ans la
première édition a eu lieu en 2010 vous
avez découvert ça comment il a fait de
l'amitié quand ça a été proposé par
l'église évangélique de voisins pour
être mis en place voilà à partir du 3
juillet j'ai parcouru un peu dossier de
presse et j'ai vu que c'est du coup ça
s'était déroulé déjà dans l'ain
notamment aussi dans le calvados et donc
ça vous a donné envie de vous dire nous
aussi on veut participer nous aussi on
veut échanger va nous la met en place la
fête de l'amitié
donc forcément on a envie d'échanger on
envie de partager que les personnes
ensuite oui j'espère que ça va donner
envie à des personnes de venir partager
ces moments avec nous et on a beaucoup
parlé de ce qui va se passer dimanche
mais c'est pas que ça on fait la fête de
l'amitié ça va jusqu'au 10 juillet qui
peut nous présenter en quelques mots les
événements qui vont arriver je crois que
ça va se passer attrapé long cours aussi
alors on a un rendez vous le mercredi
qui est très important donc à la base de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines on
va essayer de 2 voilà de toucher toutes
les personnes qui viennent les jeunes et
les moins jeunes encore une fois et puis
le mardi je respecte pas un autre
chronologique mais le mardi on sera donc
au city park de d'elancourt et le samedi
et le dimanche donc ça se passe aux
clayes sous bois alors le samedi il ya
une grosse animation avec barbecue pour
les enfants c'est au parquet au parking
rue des dames aux clayes sous bois et le
dimanche donc le dimanche à 18h le
dimanche 10 et une date à retenir
puisque j'aurai l'occasion de donner mon
spectacle qui s'appelle face à face à
l'aca le perche il y voit la perte 8e
qui se trouve à vil prix
voilà c'est un sacré programme merci
stéphane hlaing evialis gauthier d'être
venu en plateau pour nous présenter la
fête de l'amitié
elle commence dimanche 3 juillet à la au
parc la croix du bois voisins le
bretonneux
car metz et vannes et barbecue vous adam
vous attendent dès 13h et on vous disait
une représentation théâtrale clôturera
cette première journée
la commune de mon repas met à l'honneur
le vélo samedi 2 juillet dès 10h un
village d'animations vous accueillera
sur le parvis de l'hôtel de ville une
journée en deux temps avec un instant
famille ou parcours andrésienne bmx et
stands d'information sont au programme
et la journée se terminera par un run
and bike une course de 16 km elle sera
17 heures écoutez emmanuel du tas il
était au micro de nicolas d'andré force
est de constater qu'il ya un réel
engouement populaire autour du vélo je
crois que c'est une activité que chacun
peut pratiquer aisément quel que soit
l'âge quel que soit le niveau sans
esprit de compétition et avec nos
associations
ce projet est né tout naturellement pour
proposer cette activité à l'ensemble de
la population mauricienne
autre rendez vous sports et plus
national dimanche l'équipe de france
affronte l'islande en quarts de finale
de l'euro de football
un match à suivre sur écran géant allons
signer le bretonneux
michel crauste un bon jour bon je vous
êtes adjoint au maire délégué à la vie
sportive de la commune
c'est pas la première fois que vous
diffusez un mal sur écran géant
alors pourquoi montigny a souhaité leur
faire tout c'est tout simplement parce
que c'est d'abord un événement un très
important parce que c'est quand même
on a la chance d'avoir en france un
événement comme le championnat d'europe
je pense qu'on n'aura pas l'occasion
dans les 20 ou 30 prochaines années à la
voir donc c'était quand même aussi à
marquer cet événement donc on l'avait
déjà fait nous sont montés ni à travers
le village au foot
donc il ya terminé en fin de semaine
dernière est en fait par rapport à cet
événement là et on avait diffusé déjà le
match france suisse et on s'est aperçu
que pas mal de monde qui est venu voir
ce match est en fait les gens ont
vraiment manifesté l'envié d'être en
groupe d'être notre à plusieurs pour
pouvoir partager bain mais bon les moins
bons moments de ces rencontres là c'est
ce qui nous a donné l'idée effectivement
de continuer et je vais dire est qu en
plus l'idée de de continuer si l'équipe
de france va plus loin sans aucun
problème vous disiez première diffusion
match francs suisses vous aviez près de
300 personnes mais un peu plus 300
personnes vous en attendez autant on
attend plus on entend beaucoup plus
puisque là on a mis en place va pas mal
de communication donc on a en a fait des
affiches spécifiques qu'on a remis à
tous les atouts les commerçants de la
ville
on a fait pas mal de communication
auprès de tout notre tissu associatif
sportif
donc on va comme ça pour essayer d'avoir
un maximum de personnes et nous on
souhaite qu'ils aient effectivement
beaucoup de monde et ce sera nous
l'espérons une grande fête dimanche soir
puis les vacances arrivent les examens
sont terminées pour l'avoir d'entre eux
certains parents les résultats du bac
dans quelques jours donc ça peut en plus
être peut-être plus familiale encore que
les premiers matches tout à fait c'est
vraiment un grand moment de convivialité
c'est ce qui nous a poussé à faire ça
créé cet événement
sachant qu'on l'avait déjà
l'expérience d'un premier match mais on
veut on voulait on tenait absolument à
ce que rassembler toutes nos toutous
lésigny mentale et les personnes
d'autres villes alentour si elles
veulent venir le sont bien évidemment
tout à fait inviter c'est un accès libre
il n'y a pas besoin de réserver pas de
bis
absolument pas on le fait donc à
l'intérieur du gymnase pierre de
coubertin dont qui était la grande ça
donc on peut accueillir beaucoup plus de
personnes donc lier aucun souci de ce
côté-là centre pierre de coubertin peut
accueillir combien de personnes on sait
jamais si les ennemis les saint
quentinois
je peux tout une personne toute façon
j'ai de la marge de la marche
vous parlez du village euros il a fermé
ses portes le 24 juin donc de ce côté là
il ya un peu moins d'animations mais
vous proposer quand même alors dès que
des choses à côté du match tout à fait
il y aura déjà au moins une partie
restauration petit on va prendre
proposait donc à travers des fat trucks
donc de pouvoir de pouvoir se restaurer
à voir le match est bien évidemment
après le match donc sans aucun problème
de ce type d'animation banc n'a pas
poussé l'animation plus loin mais
c'était déjà en lui-même le match est
déjà d'animation met donc on verra
effectivement de quoi pourquoi passer
une très bonne soirée d'essais de
célébrer le se rassembler là aussi pour
d'un événement je retourne toute la
partie maquillage et autres on peut
faire ça y est les plus jeunes sont les
bienvenus eux aussi vont finir vont
finir la période scolaire donc la
terminer donc on espère qu'ils vont
pouvoir peut-être que les parents où
nous permettre qui veille un petit peu
plus dimanche soir le match est à 21h
quelles sont les conditions en termes
d'horaires pour se présenter au centre
ce plan nous ouvrons les portes à partir
de 20 heures
donc en fait donc vous avez pour les
prendres de sécurité dont nous aurons
effectivement malheureusement j'ai
malheureusement ou plutôt heureusement
besoin dans le dans le contexte actuel
donc des personnes qui vont qui vont
faire procéder à des fouilles
effectivement pour que tout soit
sécurisé à l'intérieur de du gymnase et
si la france arrive en données ou des et
est à demi mot tout à l'heure on punit
var provence concession en proposant
effectivement à l'asmo la diffusion du
match de demi finale
ce que nous souhaitons évidemment voir
plus loin absolument et si jamais à nos
quatre invités si vous suivez le
football un petit pronostic peut-être
pour ce week-end encore c'est sacré
c'est très très difficile ans je me
réservais à faire ce type de pronostics
d'abord parce que je suis extrêmement
mauvais
je ne dis jamais le bon bien sûr je vais
plutôt dire qu on a l'espoir que
l'équipe de france 26 mai c'est très
très belle équipe d'islande qui a qui a
donné deux petites soeurs
absolument et qui a de toute façon déjà
fait un très bon tournoi pour tout le
monde c'est la méchanceté la france
donc nous avons un avis contraire en
tout cas merci messieurs merci mme
o'shea michel scrutin alors pour
profiter du match france islande sur
écran géant en famille ou entre amis
direction le centre sportif pierre de
coubertin de montigny le bretonneux et
toujours en sport l'open de france a
débuté ce jeudi au golf national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines plus de 60000
spectateurs sont attendus sur les quatre
jours de compétition de golf devrait
attirer 40 % de personnes en plus avec
la venue du numéro trois mondial
rory mcilroy nickel et demi d'euros est
allé prendre la température à regarder
l'open de france le plus gros
rendez-vous golfique de l'hexagone a
débuté ce jeudi à saint quentin en
yvelines pour cette 100e édition les
organisateurs s'attendent à accueillir
plus de 60000 spectateurs sur les quatre
jours de compétition
les supporters ont déjà pris place à
côté des greens c'est un tournoi qui
attire beaucoup de monde donc un
passionnant avec des grands joueurs donc
c'est passionnant d'être ici je pense
que c'est un tournoi qui monte en
puissance surtout avec le la ryder cup
dans deux ans je crois que
on aura de plus en plus de grands
joueurs sur l'open de france la
vingtaine de loges de l'open de france
est également garni comme tous les ans
d'une capacité de 50 à 250 personnes les
espaces équipés de balcons accueil des
professionnels et des célébrités
ici on a la chance d'aller voir arriver
on a la chance de stresser avec eux
parce qu'il ya quand même pas mal de dos
tôt il ya du vent et il ya quelques
gouttes de pluie mais ça va pas durer
donc dans ces moments en fait on est
content de se retrouver ici
sur le plan sportif le public peut voir
en action huit vainqueurs de majeurs 87
vainqueur sur le tour et 18 jours de
ryder cup
la super star de cette édition 2016 et
le nord irlandais rory mcilroy numéro 3
mondial au niveau de vente de
billetterie
c'est important c'est énorme + 40 %
comme comme et la moyenne et on le
ressent complètement et on le sent
aujourd'hui parce qu'il ya énormément de
monde on n'a jamais vu autant demande un
jeudi le premier jour à 8 heures ce
matin ces foules le golf national fort à
ses comptes ce dimanche 3 juillet au
soir la coupe sera remise aux alentours
de 17h30 au vainqueur et un dernier
rendez vous avant de nous quitter du 1er
au 3 juillet c'est la cinquième édition
du festival my electro family pour
découvrir en famille la musique électro
direction le théâtre de verdure de
mantes la jolie
et voilà le sais tu ce week-end est
terminée je vous remercie de nous avoir
suivis je vous souhaite un excellent
week end